bei dem thema cdu viele fragen sich wie
sehr sie sich eigentlich immer noch
ärgern dass sie es nicht worden sind der
kanzlerkandidat war nicht das glaube ich
ihnen da ist aber so die entscheidung
ist gefällt worden und das ist okay die
frage ist jetzt wie wir damit umgehen
und über das beste daraus machen
in zeiten in denen wir leben sind
personen spielt die zentrale rolle ist
doch ganz selbstverständlich
es kann mir in meinem magen personen
spiele zentrale rolle denn die programme
der parteien sind nicht ganz so
jedenfalls viele nicht zu unterscheiden
da für viele menschen gibt es einen
grund vertrauen
angela merkel hat es hier mal sehr gut
bewiesen aber ja eine ganz lange zeit
hinweg erfolgreich zu sein und bei jeder
bundestagswahl lag sie dann auch
persönlich deutlich vorher jeweilige
mitbewerber also kommt es darauf an dass
man da erfolgreich ist und natürlich ist
da ein andere enttäuscht gewesen bei der
wahl auch mit der auswahl des kandidaten
möglicherweise aber das zählt jetzt
alles nichts das heißt nach vorne zu
schauen und davidson kandidaten der
union nämlich an mit lasso zugestimmt
wenn wir uns jetzt die nächsten tage
nächsten wochen anschauen und die
umfragen für armin laschet nicht weiter
nach oben gehen oder so bleiben wie sie
jetzt sind können sich vorstellen das
ist dann eine debatte in der union gibt
ob man kurz vor der wahl den kandidaten
austauschen muss nein für mich ist
völlig klar ein rasches nominiert und
armin laschet ist der kanzler eindeutig
steht ja auch dahinter und zwar zu 100
prozent aber gilt denn ihr angebot noch
an die cdu also nehmen wir an armin
laschet oder andere in der partei würden
auf die idee kommen und sagen das wird
nichts und wir rufen jetzt mal in
münchen an und fragen markus söder
ob es doch machen will wenn sie dann
bereit
ich glaube nicht dass eine solche
situation eintritt
armin laschet ist nominiert armin
laschet will von armin laschet wird aber
wären sie bereit gilt die angebot noch
an die cdu dass sie als kanzler kandidat
bereitstehen
mein angebot stetig werde armin laschet
unterstützen
fröhlich mehr jetzt hat gesagt sie
müssen über 40 holen in bayern damit was
werden kann
mit armin laschet als kanzler schaffen
sie das
ich bin total dankbar dass wir uns an
der stelle hilfestellung gibt seine
erfahrungen insbesonders den 90er jahren
die er damals als aktiver politiker
die helfen uns sicher und er ist ja
jemand der am tegernsee wohnt und es
wird schon ein halber bayern quasi ist
und insofern freuen wir uns über jede
hilfe
sie sagen wir fakten aus den 90er jahren
heißt das dass brit märz für sich jetzt
nicht so wirklich moderne politik aus
stein nein aber seine aktive politische
zeit war ja eher im kern ende der 90er
anfang des jahrhunderts gewesen
er hat natürlich eine sehr überragende
kompetenz wenn es um kapitalmärkte wenn
es um aktien geht und ähnliches mehr
hedgefonds da hat er sich in den letzten
jahren du dich als wirtschaftsexperte
einen ganz großen namen gemacht deswegen
ist es auch folgerichtig dass armin
laschet in die option dann gibt sich um
das thema finanzen in der cdu mit zu
kümmern insofern ist der rat immer
willkommen ich bin da nicht so wie sind
ich bin ja nicht immer so so so
kleinteilig wie manch einer der hinter
jedem wort hinter dem komma hinter jeder
interpunktion dann immer gleich ein
angriff setzt wir müssen an der union
als schon alles ein bisschen ins auch
wenn wir das gewinnen wollen
auch die notwendige untereinander kraft
und freiheit zugestehen dass optimal wie
möglich zu machen und da kann jeder
seinen beitrag bringen
die union ist eine große familie mit
unterschiedlichen persönlichkeiten mit
unterschiedlichen temperamenten und das
beste was wir tun können ist einander zu
unterstützen und das tun wieder mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schaue ich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren